aircrews battle flames a couple resorts
on the mountain evacuated visitors and
did closed a news out reporter Kristen
Drummond shows us how the decision
helped a popular destination prepare to
assist firefighters the general manager
at Lee Canyon tells me at least 300
people were asked to leave as a
precaution around 4:00 in the afternoon
that's a few hours earlier than normal
closing time and that's because the fire
was roughly five miles away that
decision helped the resort prepare to
fight any potential nearby flames the
resort has an eight million gallon
reservoir on property it's normally used
to make snow in the winter but is now
available as a resource for firefighters
to draw water like during the carpenter
one fire staff also spending a few hours
yesterday setting up snow making
machines on the slopes the equipment can
now blow a mist on buildings and the
mountain to deter flames the general
manager tells me staff did not need to
use the machines yet now as a reminder
Lee Canyon is normally closed during the
week and only open Friday Saturday and
Sunday during the summer months the
Mount Charleston Lodge on Kyle Canyon
Road also evacuated guests from the
restaurant yesterday I'm told the
restaurant will remain closed today
reporting at the base of the mountain
Kristen Drummond 8 news now Kristen
thank you the retreat on Charleston peak
is open it is a Comfort Center at the
moment and has a generator provided by
NV energy to power the facility and
offer assistance to Mountain residents